en este vídeo vamos a hacer unos
ejercicios muy muy bonitos dice en
pareja cada función con su gráfica y
aquí nos dan cuatro gráficas ab ab c y d
y tenemos que relacionar las o emparejar
las como dice el enunciado con las
funciones que tenemos aquí muy bien
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
identificar cada una de las gráficas con
estas funciones y las podemos acomodar
en estas cajitas digamos muy bien
entonces si nos damos cuenta todas estas
gráficas se parecen mucho a la de la
raíz cuadrada de x la raíz principal
verdad y eso es porque cada vez que
avanzamos uno a la derecha por ejemplo
en ce subimos uno si avanzamos cuatro
subimos dos y así si avanzamos nueve
subiríamos tres verdad entonces lo mismo
pasa con esto son lo que hacia abajo o
hacia la izquierda entonces todos son
variaciones de la raíz cuadrada de equis
y vamos a ver cómo poder identificar
cada una de estas con la función
correspondiente por ejemplo se se parece
ser el más
fácil de todos porque simplemente la
raíz cuadrada pero trasladada hacia la
izquierda dos unidades y hacia abajo dos
unidades
entonces vemos nuestras opciones y de
las cuatro opciones la única que
traslada hacia abajo dos unidades es p y
h muy bien sin embargo en h nos damos
cuenta que aquí está el traslado dos
unidades a la izquierda verdad
recordemos que si sumamos dos dentro de
la raíz entonces estamos trasladando dos
a la izquierda entonces la función hdx
corresponde a la gráfica c
vamos a ver qué pasa por ejemplo con
2020 son digamos la misma excepto que
están trasladadas distinta altura ve
está trasladada una unidad hacia arriba
y de esta trasladada tres unidades hacia
arriba
y de hecho están ambas trasladadas dos
hacia la derecha quiere decir que si
están trasladadas dos aldeas hacia la
derecha tendremos algo así como x menos
2 sin embargo no tenemos que abren a la
izquierda verdad entonces tenemos menos
x menos 2 dentro de la raíz que
corresponde a 2 - x verdad que es 2 - x
o menos x + 2 entonces ésta está
trasladada uno hacia arriba así que
corresponde a b y la gráfica de
correspondería a la gtx que está
trasladada a tres unidades hacia arriba
muy bien entonces está g corresponde a
la gráfica de muy bien y ahora
finalmente pues la única que nos queda
es p de x que corresponde a la gráfica
de ahí queda muy bien verdad porque
fíjense que está en realidad abre hacia
abajo ok lo cual justifica este signo
menos que tiene aquí está trasladada
hacia abajo 2 unidades lo cual está muy
bien porque tiene un -2 y está
trasladado hacia la derecha 4 unidades
lo cual justifica porque está aquí el
menos 4 entonces después de todos estos
vídeos yo creo que ya tienes muy bien
muy buena intuición y muy buena práctica
de cómo identificar gráficas o cómo
construir gráficas o ecuaciones según
sea el caso de funciones radicales
espero te haya servido mucho y te hayas
divertido